[Musique]
je suis venu vous raconter une histoire
une histoire assez banal en fait et je
pense que c'est en sa cape être
intéressante parce que du coup vous
l'avez certainement déjà vécu ou au
moins vous connaissez quelqu'un qui l'a
vécu cette histoire c'est l'histoire
d'un demi qui est née il ya une
vingtaine d'années à peu pied en
polynésie sa maman est né à talence à
côté de bordeaux et sans papa est née à
papeete combi ce 2000 à de grands mères
une blanche
mamie qui n'est pas l'enfant sait et qui
lui apprend comment c'était la seconde
guerre mondiale quand elle était en
métropole
et puis la une rome est bronzée mahou
les ballons tahitien qui lui apprend à
pêcher à tiquer au ce et demi sa vie va
se rendre compte qu'ils parlent foncier
pas trop mal mais qui parle pas tahitien
ces salles embête c'est demi ou là les
complices et moi et cette histoire en
fait j'espère qu'on l'a vécu
je vais vous livrer ce soir ma récent de
cette histoire la première partie n'est
pas forcément intéressante entre 0 et 20
ans à ce jeu je suis au contact du
tahitien tous les jours mais c'est pas
c'est pas le moment fondamental
juste une petite anecdote je m'appelle
buteur pour tout le monde est en fait
pour moi où je m'appelle irina elle m'a
jamais appelé par mon pays occidental et
je savais que à l'extérieur je
m'appelais peter et ce avec à
l'intérieur je m'appelle jean
en fait je pensais aussi qu'à
l'extérieur mon nom de famille c'était
meules et qu'à l'intérieur mon nom de
famille s'était améliorée parce que le
disait souvent tous les gens qui n'ont
pas grandi avec une loi mais trahissent
l agneau et ça veut dire
calme toi sinon le balayant va pas
laisser dans le coin de ces longtemps ça
en faisait l'eau et 20 ans ensuite j'ai
continué mes études j'ai la chance de
pouvoir faire de ma passion mes études
et maintenant mon travail l'informatique
ces études menées à montpellier et à
montpellier ça se passe bien je du matin
jusqu'au soir je fais que l'informatique
j'ai des collègues de classe tout va
bien
et au bout d'un moment je me rends
compte qu'en fait c'est ses camarades
avec qui je partage une passion mais
bientôt un métier on pense pas pareil
on réfléchit pas et on réagit pas de la
même façon même chose et pour tout dire
en fait on n'a pas du tout la même
mentalité
donc en fait je suis français comme eux
mais je suis pas français comme peu et
il ya un autre aspect en fait de ma vie
à montpellier c'est que j'ai un accent à
60 ans et les gens me demandent d'où tu
viens et je dis de tahiti et on me dit
ah j'aime beaucoup haïti et le nom là il
dit en fait à tahiti et là en fait tu as
une
non julien devait avouer que ça à côté
et on commence à comprendre que on vient
d'un endroit un peu différent de tous
les autres quand on voit comment les
gens accueillent d'état issa les
polynésiens on se dit qu'on a quand même
de la chance semble en compte
en vivant sans doute quelques mois yann
où il ya une formation en moi qu'est ce
qui se passe c'est que en polynésie je
suis polynésiens voilà le poisson est
dans l'eau on lui demande comment elle
est à température de l'eau voilà mais en
métropole je suis polynesia je me l'ont
quand je suis différent que je viens de
polynésie et j'en deviens fièvre ne
m'étais jamais posé la question mais je
vois la différence et je me dis je suis
polynésiens mais se le dire c'est bien
c'est ensuite en fatigue c'est un peu
différent donc on peut se prétendre
polynésiens mais faut quand même on l'a
en en a pas et oeuvre pour jouer un peu
du ukulélé faut savoir faire sont pas
aussi et c'est là et donc je me prend de
passion pour ma culture
et quand on est à montpellier quand on
est étudiant l'endroit de prédilection
infos pratiques et sa culture c'est
l'association des étudiants de polynésie
française pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas dit le foyer il y en a plusieurs en
métropole celui de mon pull et les et le
meilleur est en fait au fil des ans et
au gré des bonnes volontés au foyer vous
pouvez prendre des cours de danse de
chant de langues
il ya des jeunes et culturels entre le
ier madea des métropolitains et et ça
sera super bien en fait donc
c'est un petit bout de culture
polynésienne en métropole et j'y vais
c'est génial et roule un moment je vois
des gens à côté de moi
il chante il danse il joue aussi bien
que moi voilà plus que moi sauf qu'ils
sont pas nés en polynésie en jeu ça me
dérange pas du tout je suis je suis
content de voir que la culture dans
laquelle je suis né passionne d'autres
personnes d'autres cultures c'est génial
mais moi j'étais venu pour un vrai
polynésiens c'est le gars à côté
il chante aussi bien que moi qu'est ce
qui fait de moi un vrai polynésiens là
je suis embêté et puis je cherchais puis
et je me dis que si le temps d'une
soirée un peu fait est bon pas dedans
soit avoir eu les bons gestes là quelque
chose qui s'improvise pas en fait là
quelque chose qui ne s'apprend pas au
point de la table c'est de parler
tahitien une autre langue polynésienne
et donc voilà je suis tout fier de moi
j'ai trouvé le marc de maar aux études
je vais pas les tahitiens la langue
comme appât et depuis que je suis petit
je vais enfin la pratique et je suis
content les vacances suivant john
rafferty j'achète tous les bouquins tous
le bleu le vert le orange levée flash
attendu en double exemplaire ce que
j'avais oublié je l'avais achetée
l'année d'avant et puis je vais à se les
mois ou tous les jours pourquoi n'y pas
encore plus en tahitien elles font écho
particulier bref je me lance et c'est
génial c'est génial parce que ce
mouvement d'apprentissage il me la
plante donc du fait d'être polis parce
qu'avant d'avoir ce tatouage et même
comme ça c'est pas évident mais quand
j'étais à l'aéroport de tahiti faa'a
on veut parler en anglais parce qu'on
sait que j'étais un tout liste quand
j'étais à l'aéroport de charles de
gaulle on me parlait en russe spacieux
avec mon air jamais personne m'a dit tu
viens de thierry titouan jamais s'est
jamais arrivé donc voilà j'attends le
tahitien je me lance je suis content je
suis passionné je suis motivé
et au bout de quelques mois j'ai
progressé certes mais je ne suis pas
capable de tenir une conversation en
tahitien je ne parle pas tahitien tout
simplement jamais dans un coin de ma
charge des pieds je me pose la question
pourquoi qu'est ce qui se passe est en
fait la solution est évidente
j'ai beau avoir les capacités j'espère
le temps la motivation j'ai pas les bons
outils
tous les bouquins que j'ai achetés ne
sont pas les bons c'est une technique de
mex quand vous avez un problème vous
regardez ailleurs quelqu'un accusé
donc si je n'y arrivais pas c'est parce
que je n'avais pas les bons outils la g
elles savent à la conjugaison j avis en
fait ce qui me manque c'est le
vocabulaire parce qu'on le sait en fait
les langues polynésiennes et son image
et sens poétique le vocabulaire
extrêmement importants et moi mais mes
dictionnaires ils font 4 kg je peux pas
les mettre dans mon sac
il faut tourner des pages en papier
papier que je suis informaticien
donc c'est comme ça qu'en 2000 ans à je
me lance dans la première version de
l'application à lexique vous tapez un
mot en tahitien ça vous donne atrix en
français ou en français ça vous la donne
en tahitien quelques heures quelques
jours j'ai mon application qui fonction
de ses biens
sauf que c'est un contenant cette
coquille il faut quelque chose dedans
et là c'est la fait la pole je fais une
application pour la plante le
vocabulaire en tahitienne mais elle est
vite parce que je ne connais pas le
vocabulaire en tahitien donc je
contacter des gens qui ont fait des
dictionnaires qui en fait des lexiques
et ils sont de bonne volonté il ya des
problèmes de voix ça se fait pas le le
format du fichier n'est pas le vent etc
ils veulent pas en 2017 grâce aux deux
ont mis celle de la culture des glaçons
chargé de la traduction et de
l'interprétariat âgées au sort et là je
suis content je suis fier comme pau mais
je suis surtout enfin enfin je vais
pouvoir apprendre le tahitien parce que
ce qui me manquait c'était évident
c'était juste une application c'est ça
qui va faire la différence et ça me fait
plaisir de participer donc fait d'un
outil pour qu'on puisse
apprendre cette langue parce que il ya
quand même un aspect magique au
numérique
un outil informatique c'est que ça aide
énormément si demain vous voulez
apprendre island et il n'y a pas
beaucoup de courrier demandé à du pf
par contre vous pouvez aller sur
internet je voulais quelqu'un plancher
de votre logiciel de visioconférence et
discuter avec cette personne vous pouvez
apprendre n'importe quelle langue
aujourd'hui ça vaut cool tahitien on est
même arrivé à un niveau où il ya des
logiciel de visioconférence en fait qui
intègre la traduction instantanée
vous êtes français vous valait 1 et ce
landais ou pas les enfoncer le logiciel
je connais ce que vous avez dit le
traduit en islande et l'envoi de l'autre
côté du monde est en fait le logiciel du
collège fondante synthétiser vocalement
ce que vous avez dit mais en islande et
la personne ne voulait pas et vous vous
entendez du fond c'est donc en fait
aujourd'hui on est capable de parler
dans sa langue natale à quelques notes
qui lui aussi par là dans sa langue
natale
c'est quand même assez magique le saut
si on a ce genre d'outil c'est qu'au
bout d'un moment à se demander à quoi
bon apprendre une langue
à quoi bon apprendre des langues puisque
avec un logiciel je peux comprendre
beaucoup plus que je pouvais en appelant
du on va commencer à se refermer sur soi
pour moi plan d'une longue tout l'avais
dit c'était d'être un vrai polynésiens
c'était un mouvement radio que je vous
lève c'est connu comme tel et il me
fallait ça il me fallait le tatouage il
me fallait le dos façon d'une poule
élite il me fallait savoir parler en
tahitien est donc dix-huit mois se sont
écoulés j'utilise tous les jours très
haut et donc je peux vous dire que je ne
sais toujours pas à l'état haïtien
j'en suis pas fiers du tout mais c'est
comme ça donc là je me mets dans un coin
de ma chambre je nous mets un défi mais
je me dis pourquoi j'ai tous les
capacités j'espère j'ai tout la
motivation j'ai lu durant la joute i7
compliqué de faire une excuse
et je comprends pas pourquoi mon pied
par les tahitiens se lancer en attente
on a peur on a peur de se tromper et
c'est stupide c'est pas stupides chacun
sa vie mais c'est bizarre parce que
quand on va parler anglais ou espagnol
luis l'on dit c'est pas grave en fait de
faire des fautes ans on fiche mais quand
on va pas les tahitiens à marchisio pour
nous tous on a peur de faire des fautes
je parle mais pas pour les autres mais
pour moi cette est évidente c'est
parce que chaque faute que je fais des
fautes dans un enfant de 5 ans ne fait
pas montre justement que je ne suis pas
fait partie de ce groupe
depuis ma naissance montrent pas que je
suis peut-être apporter mais que je ne
suis pas un objet polynésiens fesci
soria qui devinent deuxième raison à ce
manque de motivation en fait de ne pas
avoir réussi et cette deuxième des ans
c'est qu'en fait finalement j'ai plus
besoin d'être reconnu comme un objet
polynésiens sans le savoir
j'ai suivi le conseil de nietzsche qui
disait deviens qui tu es en polynésie en
vivent en participant à des projets
culturels en faisant des applications
juste en m'impliquant ans vivent sous le
joug
je suis devenu qui gt20 polynésiens
parmi tant d'autres et ma mawi tuba jeu
la vie c'est pas la mare aux études mais
c'en est une
et c'est la mienne en fait aujourd'hui
elle me suffit elle me suffit donc du
coup c'est bien parce que moi j'ai réglé
mon problème d'identité
la convergence et que je veux quand même
je veux apprendre le talent est cher je
veux le parler
parce que c'est la langue de ma grand
mère c'est la langue de mao et plus que
les souvenirs plus que les photos et
plus que les tifs effet c'est vraiment
cette langue qui m'unit à elle et à
chaque fois que je la parle je parle
tahitien me suis caché jeudi à rimatara
personnes de mon temps et où je peux
attaquer ça mais n'ont pas beaucoup de
gens ça me rappelle ma grand mère ils
sont en faisant ce travail
d'introspection que je vous livre ce
soit que j'ai trouvé en fait ma nouvelle
source de motivation est en fait c'est
tout simplement la gratitude la
gratitude de vie dans ce petit coin de
paradis qui est quand même sacrément
bien plus élevé du reste du monde et
aqua talent à dire jolie tu es là ça
suffit pas il faut des jolies gens
dessus et ce qui m'intéresse c'est que
nous préservions et que nous fassions
prospérer notre phare de vivre cette
gentillesse sa spontanéité mais mes
premières années à montpellier était
très difficile parce que je souriais
comme un idiot et les jambes elysées 21
il est idiot mais c'est naturel ça fait
partie de nous et c'est beau c'est ça
qui fait qu'on vit ensemble et du coup
que j'allais vous proposer ce soir en
échange si vous voulez bien de tout ce
que je vais vous raconter
faites vous inviter à faire un voyage et
ce voyage c'est celui d'apprendre une
langue polynésienne n'importe laquelle
parce que le but ça fait quinze jours
tout le monde en polynésie pâle au moins
une langue polynésienne
parce que comme ça on pourrait échanger
on pouvait se comprendre dans ces
langues qui appelle ce partage qui
appelle à l'imagination ne pas oublier
d'où nous venons et pour savoir où nous
allons
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]